ich war im gleichen Restaurant wie Drake
essen als wir in LA waren wollten wir es
uns an einem Abend besonders gut gehen
lassen also waren wir im Novum Malibu
dem Restaurant der Stars die Kardashians
Justin Bieber und Drake gehen hier ein
und aus perfekt zubereitetes Sushi Tatar
mit crispyrice und natürlich der Novus
signature dich Hamachi mit Jalapeno und
JUSO waren unglaublich an unserem Platz
auf der Terrasse saßen wir direkt am
Meer und der perfekte Service hat unsere
Erfahrung abgerundet ein Restaurant
besucht den wir mit Sicherheit niemals
vergessen werden und die Rechnung zu 6
haben wir 822 $ und 35 Cent bezahlt ob
es sich wirklich gelohnt hat das kann
ich nicht sagen aber immerhin kann ich
sagen